have you ever wondered what happens to
the recycling once it goes inside the
recycling truck well it comes here to
seven disability enterprises where it's
unloaded hand sorted bailed and
processed and sent off to other
countries to be made into new products
here at the center is the loader driver
loads up there with materials
puts it onto a conveyor belt and from
those conveyor belts they get sorted
into different products
how are things going to tour the recycle
center so Aaron is putting on some steel
strapping so that keeps our bale
together and we bail out the products
because that makes it cheaper to ship
overseas show up behind me with these
people hand sorting the Hellerman you
man plastic can go in space along the
short line we'll be looking for a
different product wine are we taking off
the aluminum cans run the milk bottles
one the color Spectre bottles and now
that will be taking the janitorial and
mixed products and in anything that
isn't on the person to look after will
come at the end and in start the process
all over again
so once the plastics have been veiled
they get stuck out here inside because
we don't want them getting wet and then
they'll be veiled up with potato foam to
be shipped overseas to be made into new
products
so behind me the sorting out the paper
so this is all your newspaper cardboard
boxes junk mail envelopes that come in
to be recycled so a cycling system takes
whole glass bottles and jars and this
bin full of glass is the product that we
get off the line so as you can see we do
get a little bit of broken stuff coming
across so the only whole glass bottles
and jars you should go into the system
to help us and limit the breakage that
comes across this bin is going to be
going out to a quarry to the users
eroding aggregate or a construction
material so that was a quick trip around
the recycling center I hope you enjoyed
your time and remember recycle